le bord du fleuve une place du village
comme un petit monde à part et pourtant
on est en nette hausse renault planète
non en est à montréal cette réflexion ne
lui vient pas en tête pour la quiétude
des lieux mais pour ces difficultés de
recrutement et envoient leurs cv on les
convoque en entrevue pillay nous
rappelle ben j'ai pas de voiture j'ai
joué au bonheur ne faut pas pointer au
tram c'est bien trop loin c'est tout le
monde est au diapason ici le renne
faciliterait la vie décent commerciaux
comme la place versailles les galeries
d'anjou c'est très lent veut se trouver
un job dans le centre-ville il pourrait
très bien mais pour l'instant on tente
encore de recoller les morceaux
politique entre québec et montréal on va
faire une belle annonce d'un beau projet
ajuster la mairesse est tellement de
bonne humeur qui apprécie pleinement le
projet qu'elle a dit qu'elle se sentait
acculé au pied du mur ce que la mer est
ce trou c'est que certains déjà
anglaises sont un peu de jeu dans les
négociations
est-ce que minimalement la ville de
montréal pourrait être impliqué dans le
comité décisionnel valérie plante a
donné en exemple pour appuyer cette
demande il ya deux semaines on a appris
que le tracé sur sherbrooke et est
maintenant sûr souligné mais on l'a
appris la veille quant à la ministre
chargée du dossier je vais présenter une
nouvelle carte qui montre que l'est sera
enfin relié aux grands réseaux
métropolitains et dans son épicerie fine
cette commerçante y croit moi je suis
partisane parce qu'apple lancera ce mal
qui est allée du belgian d'alcool c'est
comme ça je vois ça plus on va être
intéressant plus on aura déjà intéressé
à nous connaître mais trop de la balle
le plus bel exemple est on prêt on
projette 12mail 8000
utilisateurs par jour première journée
40 mais sans jamais baisser le transport
le mode de transport qui va nous
permettre de transformer le territoire
d'attirer de densifier et de créer de la
valeur certes le projet est parfait mais
il ne semble plus être menacée ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal